the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
hello everybody and welcome to our
coverage of the 2022 fall chess classic
I am happy to be here my name is
Jonathan schrance and I'm joined today
by Eugenie Miro shinichenko it's a
pleasure to have you here with us today
uh well my pleasure to be here yeah and
not to make you pronounce my honorable
honorable second name all the time I go
by Miro that's perfect if it's possible
I think we'll be going with mural from
now on and we actually have a lot of
competitors in this that have very
difficult names to pronounce so let's
just jump into it let's get right to the
action and let's see who is playing in
this event this is actually a tournament
that is broken up into two different
sections and in the a group which has an
average rating of about 26.50 we have uh
two 2700 rated players we got vidit
guthrothy and you Yang Yi and right
below him we got Hans Neiman sitting
there from the United States of America
at 26.99 now you might even be able to
recognize a couple of other regular
names we got ilionic who you've maybe
seen here live on Twitch streaming for
the St Louis chess club uh before and
this will actually conclude who we got
going on in the a group now let's see
who's talking so the big group uh while
I do see familiar names like I will
actually rate it well somewhere at the
bottom but Christian kirilla who you
guys might know as the commentator for
Saint Louis chess club as well so he is
actually about to prove that he can play
chess okay we really hope for that uh
but he's not one of the tops in fact on
top position we have raunak sadwani from
India 26 28 and Then followed by Dennis
cuddridge Jan uh American I believe
American talent Christopher you and it
goes on and on
wonderful and let's actually take a look
now at our tournament format to get to
know what uh time controls and
everything that these guys are playing
this is going to be a 10 player round
robin so that's nine days of Chess in a
row starting today they are going to be
playing with 90 minutes for the first 40
moves they get 30 minutes at move 40 and
they'll have that for the rest of the
game and all throughout even from move
one they get that 30 second increment so
I guess a pretty standard time control
uh you might say not the longest one of
all uh but definitely something
interesting now Miro could you please
let us know about the schedule yeah well
the schedule is once again I want to say
pretty standard to well to what I'm used
to play of course like Elite tournaments
they tend to have three days but no free
days for us it's pretty straightforward
1pm start of the round all the rounds
from one to eight in on a last day
November 10th we will start two hours
earlier because in case we need playoffs
we will have playoffs and they will be
played on the same last day
that is wonderful and just to let you
guys know that this time we are actually
trying to do something a little bit
special for you guys over on social
media if you guys do want to talk to us
please use the hashtag fall chess
classic or watch all of the games live
on uschess champs.com and this time
we're actually trying to make everything
a little bit more interactive we got the
twitch chat we got the YouTube chat
wherever you are in the world if you're
chatting right now uh we are going to be
able to see it so uh hello a little bit
to Elka hello to everybody that's
talking in the chat uh you maybe you'll
be able to get a special shout out we'll
be keeping our eye on that and just so
you know all of the revenue that we do
make from YouTube and also from Twitch
in the form of bits and subscriptions it
all goes to fund uh children getting a
chess education in their school so just
every 75 dollars that we raise we'll get
a semester of programming for a child
that will get approximately 10 different
programs with a grand master lesson in
their class and this will help them
receive a chess education that they
might not otherwise be able to have so
with that all being in mind could you
please just tell us a little bit Miro
about the pairings and Groupon well
let's find out all together so round one
in group a we have Ilya niznik facing
Gregorio parin then Indian Derby Ganguly
against vidit Gujarati you Yang Yi
facing one yen around any playing each
other I believe this game might conclude
any time and then the one game that we
basically we were thrilled about but
regrettably it's already over it's a
draw for Nicolas Theodore and Hans
Neiman so Han starts with a solid role
with black uh well perhaps Nicholas can
be happy that he plays on average better
than Magnus Carson he's notorious to
lose with white against uh well if it is
possible can we actually go through this
game I think this is awesome yeah fans
are probably most looking forward yeah
absolutely so that's get an idea by the
way I just figured out so that's move 40
and that's the first time you're allowed
to offer a draw by the rules of this
tournament you no drove was before move
40 whenever they've reached it well
perhaps here it's fair to say it's not
much left the plate but yeah but just
quickly we'll uh well click through the
game so it started with
uh D5 G3 a check on B4
well nowadays very very common line
against the Catalan for whatever reason
black prefers to lose the tempo okay
I'll actually stop making fun of it and
we'll explain what's the point right so
after Castle well actually I I was
always thinking that C6 is somewhat more
precise moves over but yeah 97 Works
anyway the point being that the bishbone
D2 is sort of misplaced in fact and very
often white just moves the bishop for a
second time that means black didn't lose
a Tempo or yeah
Queen C2 C6 Bishop F4 here you go so
that's what that's move nine and you
could have this same position on
movement eight if black doesn't play a
check right in white plays Bishop c one
two F4 in one go
all that being uh well once again is
standard line C takes D5 I guess here is
what uh where you have a choice because
there are other moves I'm sure of the
cd5 cd5 Rook C1 white is trying for this
like really tiny minimal Advantage right
says and no big things happens no breaks
in the center nothing just white
controls the C file tries to be on a
safe side but also kind of to push a
little uh pretty much the situation you
want to be against hunts I don't think
you want to make him angry so Rook takes
Queen takes Knight C3 I don't know what
the plan was for white for this game but
it seems that he was always like more of
a
um support of being on a stronger side
rather than anything else or but not the
song is safer sidebarring
and yeah so you see everything
symmetrical pieces are kind of getting
hovered away from the board slowly but
surely
and then we trade the other guys yeah
like like you can see the C5 square that
perhaps the only hope for white to
achieve something substantial if let's
say he's able to trade the doctor
bishops get the Knight on C5 maybe there
is hope but yeah but Hans was in fact
very precise here Knight is transferred
to C6 and I guess if you move the bishop
back then black can actually think of
grabbing a bit of space with B4 and this
bishop is kind of passive just a little
bit so Bishop goes to C5 but that allows
black to jump to B4 trade these guys
later on trade the other guys I believe
black is fine if he captures but there
is no need to such as Bishop D7 A5
and there is one weakness for black but
one weakness as we all know is not
enough you need a second one and F5 he
just blocks and so this is where this
one kind of came to an end and we've
only just begun our commentary Journey
but I want to ask you a little bit of a
question before we hop in and see some
of the other games uh just because I
think this is the one that I think
everyone is is probably talking about
today or at least had anticipated coming
in we're seeing a lot of people play the
Catalan and I guess as somebody that's
you know only recently started watching
every Don's Neiman game it seems like
he's defending this with the black
pieces quite a bit do you think this is
like a good option for people with the
white pieces to try to play for a major
advantage at least that you know this
top level yeah well honestly I'm not
sure it's it's perhaps for um for a lack
of a better better options to be honest
because
uh if we are perfectly honest so well
it's not a lot of stuff you can do with
white nowadays because like
it's either you play C4 and go in the
waters of English opening where well a
few years back I would say you have a
fresh position from move five but not
anymore like even in English opening
it's like 20 minutes of theory and
everything's equal and then after D4 you
have like a lot of other headaches like
the groomfield is the big thing and then
then the Nim so and so on and so on so
when you're finally getting the Catalan
from the app okay at least I I have a
try right it's not much what it can do
it I mean the state of an open interior
on the high level once again is that
it's not there looking for Advantage
with white you're looking for the game
right so to avoid your opponent making a
draw without playing a single move over
the boards a Catalan in this regard at
least gives you some chances so I guess
that's that's the explanation and
especially in our case when Nicholas he
is rated about 100 points lower than
Hans once again probably
especially at the start of a tournament
you don't really want you know to play a
crazy game with white and lose in round
one and then then how do you continue
yeah it's a very respectable start and
this is actually not the only game that
we have going
and entirely other section the
little chess classic uh in Miro if you
would please go ahead and let us know
what's going on there so here the grand
harodan is playing with Christian
chirilla Christopher Ryu has the white
pieces against Brandon Jacobson I'll
explain them on with gergley kanta from
Hungary I believe right Dennis cadreich
Montenegro board one faces akshat
Chandra and then raunak sawani with
Armand Michael learn I think that that's
the top rated game all game and that
actually looks like a really interesting
one is that one that we can jump to and
you take a little bit of look and see
what they've been doing uh let me update
the the this one just quickly uh he
there yeah yeah okay so that's quite an
interesting development because the
rounds as far as I understand they
started at the same time and then Hans
already like they've played it out in
the end game with only bishops and kings
on the board like a lot of Pawns right
here uh pay attention on the board it
ladies and gentlemen it's just a pair of
Bishops being swapped and that's it like
all eight pawns age
it's move 22 and once again I mean we
were discussing before the show when you
see this structure for white and
especially these doubled pawns and you
know C4 E4 setup I personally would
think that there was something from
English opening the Reversed rosalima
variation I have to specify it like
rosalima is Bishop B5 In the Sicilian
and then nowadays against in Bishop and
it's very popular to go Bishop B4 and
then take on C3
and I was wrong entirely because in fact
it was e45 neither freedom of Sig Bishop
C4 and with slight transposition so
Knight F6 D3 Bishop C5 it is a Joko
piano and Jaco piano is
the opening I'll never comprehend
honestly I mean I did try it at some
point open the database and was trying
to follow you know the big guys that's
usually how it works you're interested
in some position you open the database
you look at highest rated plays what
they did turns out over here they do
absolutely everything so there is no way
at all understanding the move orders and
so on so basically what happens like
white opts to play d3d4 but
interestingly enough whenever he gets
the chance like here for example of a
castle he's not in hurry to do so
because then it's really hard to develop
the Bishop from B1
so he goes with H3 first to stop Knight
G4 perhaps and ideally you want to play
Knight D2 F1 G3 and only then go for D4
right but Black's not waiting of course
A5 and A5 is sort of a modern take
because very often they would play A6
and then was the idea of course to hide
the bishop on A7 after A6 white quite
often would go b4a4 see some space on it
Queen side and then someone clever said
and what did we play five why don't we
still stop this B4 for good night BD to
B2 Bishop B6 and yeah perhaps okay I
mean I was sarcastic most of the time
but here it is actually important uh so
in A7 A6 line they usually tend to play
Rook E8 before going to E6 and why is
that so Bishop E6
uh White actually didn't take on E6 so
if white captures only six fe6 with the
pawn on East with the pawn here on A6
not on A5 it is considered the why why
it goes B4 A4 has quite some space on
the Queen's a white is for some reason
once again I was told by the big guys by
say Peter's web light yeah Russian
Champion so he explained this to me so
why it's considered to be better with
the pawn on A6 and him having some space
on the queen side
and then with the pawn on A5 this is not
dangerous for black what server so black
just gives Bishop E6 he's he's not
scared of anything
all right and white plays B3 Ah that's
uh Rubenstein maneuver but this is at
the beginning
yeah that's a very very interesting
sequence yeah like Rook the D.A
oh yeah Bishop B2 was also amazing but
like you expect something along the
lines of Bishop E3 yeah and so on and
anyway it does something on this
diagonals but now
as far as I get it D4 somewhere
like from a perhaps of like from playing
97 because D4 maybe that's the reason
anyway Bishop B2 black eventually
accomplishes here this is how we got to
this structure and then um
continuous Knight G3 is not so weird
quite common Knight to E7 to stop Knight
F5 uh Rook B5 Bishop C5 back Bishop to
C1 back C6 Rook to B1 back well just
wasting your time a little bit Bishop A7
Knight H4 rookie eight Queen E2
here we are right now
um I'm not sure if black enjoys
he was the one who spent some time to
bring it there but now that
no one nobody is going to open the sun
okay why it's not going to open the
center but white brought all his well
not all but most of his stuff towards
the king side and then the last minute
Queen F3 kind of confirms on that so
Knight F5 is going to be played later
sooner or later and this King might be
in danger so I believe yeah there is
some something to be worried with black
some very good chances here to stir up
some sort of attack with the white
pieces so we're going to be keeping our
eye on this I have also just heard we
have a little bit of breaking news I
believe one of these games is
potentially over if we could take a look
at the game between abisov and Jacobian
uh
or maybe oh yeah we haven't finished if
the game hasn't finished yet we might be
getting yeah yeah let's see
that's very well that actually is
amazing because not only it's almost
over it's uh well it's 21 move and black
seems to be winning so somebody went
terribly wrong we can just we can check
from the beginning so once again so
nothing special knight c3c5 so-called
semi Taurus right C takes D5 and then
it's not even semitarish because night
night takes E4 Knight C3 is what I'm
talking about yeah and in this game c
takes D4 I guess nowadays it it perhaps
is more popular moved it's been played
by yeah do you feel like I've seen this
one at least yeah yeah yeah a little bit
more these days yeah so well the whole
thing is about a check on A4 Bishop D7
Queen D4 the whole debate one is it
played for black or not it was it was
this yeah he takes D5 Knight takes D5
and uh yeah I think black just captures
girls Knight C6 sacrifices the pawn like
that but I love it yeah yeah yeah but
that's apparently not what happens yeah
no no no no he just captured the only
five with the Knight Knight D5 Bishop D2
so quite a modest setup Bishop E7 E3
castles Bishop E2 black went with E5 and
here now first captures on D5 here here
so that was and here the the pause you
know white one Knight B5 kind of went
all in and it turned to be a terrible
move so what white had to do was either
Bishop F3 where you provoke E4 go back
and pretend that the Knight on D4 is
strong apparently it is or you just go
back Knight F3 which if black wants it
might lead to the same position of the
E4 and Knight back to D4 I suppose the
problem is that the g-pawn is actually
hanging yeah but you can take it I mean
he's scary he probably did not blunder
the the queen G2 thing yeah which was
yeah which happened so white reason to
go there was that I play Bishop F3 with
the temple you move the queen away and
I'm winning The Rook right but but it's
very often so that if you spend that
much time to take the piece which is not
participating in the game right you kind
of lack a lot on initiative and so on
and that's exactly what happened in this
game so Knight to A6
Knight takes A8 uh perhaps it was still
I know it's too late I wanted to say it
was not too late to take on A6 but
you're pulling down with King stuck in
the center so you you pretty much have
to take and then night before happens
and then you can't really as far as I
understand you can't really take right
because a check here well King F1 runs
into Bishop H3 King E2 there is E4 think
yeah like you win the bishop the king is
on the terrible attack by the way the
threat is not even to take the visual
but Queen A6 Checkmate into another
that's a disaster wonderful stuff that's
a disaster so night before he apparently
underestimated I mean white
underestimated this line Queen went to
A4 a check on C2 King E2 and black says
I'm not interested in taking any Rooks
Rook to d8 once again a strat of Queen
D3 check
Queen to C4
Bishop E6 why not Queen E4 you might ask
but that's exactly what happens a queen
E4 Bishop F5 could have been the same
from C8 so it doesn't really matter
Queen B7 a check
finally takes the rook and then what a
move that is King C1 Bishop B1 I love
those moves I love those movies I better
be one so it threatens the Checkmate in
one white absolutely has to play E4 and
then Bishop captures on A2
Bishop D1 Bishop to G5 I mean black
attacks every possible angle F4 Queen D6
and while I was showing the previous
moves the game in fact has ended wow and
with that we see uh Ninja actually
taking an early lead in this competition
so that's really cool to see and it is
also worth taking a little bit of time
to see what these guys are actually
playing for and taking a look at the
prize fund for each one of these fields
so we'll be starting off uh with the a
section and taking a look at the prize
funds they are competing for 22 000 US
Dollars and the top prize is a six
thousand dollar person somebody could be
walking away with uh then second place
is four thousand third place is three
thousand it goes all the way down and
everybody will be walking out of here
with at least a thousand dollars for
nine days of work
and now let's go ahead and take a look
at the B group and see what is going on
there oh yeah the B group I believe yeah
well it's slightly smaller share of a
price font but still four thousand
dollars for the first place two and a
half two thousand and so on and so forth
and I believe okay I'm not sure if it's
official but the winner of the B group
allegedly gets into a group the next
year right I mean okay
it's almost better than the price fund
for a lot of these people
and we also have a little bit more
breaking news it turns out that abisov
who just we just saw that's a very
decisive beautiful victory has blessed
us with an interview so we are going to
go ahead this is a little bit of a new
feature here this is our first interview
uh and let's see what he had to say
about his game
so the line is quite calm
but then I went to E5 and that moment I
felt like I already managed to equalize
and later on he went for move 11 Knight
B5 what was kind of the turning point of
the game it was quite a principal line
because if not this move then I'm
completely okay but this move is also
itself is a risky like he's sacrificing
the pawn on G2 and well in fact wins my
Rook on A8 but his King is also getting
stuck in the in the center so it's very
double-edged but it felt very risky for
me like what he does and I went for this
sacrifice Queen takes G2 and there was
already not turning back uh neither for
him nor for me but luckily for me it's
everything just hurts works well oh it's
lovely to hear a great time starting off
with the black piece with a nice Victory
we hope to see you in later on see you
back and good luck in our snaps thank
you very much thank you very much
thank you very much for that interview
and I just want to let you know that we
are keeping our eyes on the chat shout
out to Jay beast and everybody else
that's watching some people were asking
you know is they are we using a VHS
style tape well no actually that was our
very own Jacob Sanders who was doing his
first ever recording editing he did
everything to make that interview
possible so big shout out to Jacob for
being able to let us uh interview some
of these players and that's going to
become a recurring thing throughout
these episodes so uh with that in mind
maybe it would make a little bit of
sense here there's so many games going
on we only have so much time uh is it
possible to just kind of go around the
horn and let's kind of take a look yeah
let's start with the a group of course
and we do have three three results
already so that's the one from a bus of
and we already know yeah it finished was
the beautiful Bishop B1 and the wind for
black we now we are aware of a draw for
Hans Neiman and there was one more draw
for Ileana and Gregorio yeah I think
there's a lot of Polynesians fans out
there he does quite a lot of streams on
our twitch channel so there might be
some interest in seeing what he did
today look like confirming on my words
that Bishop B4 nowadays again he's very
popular right there oparing went for it
on move too and then Nitric actually
decided to keep his the Integrity of his
Pawn structure well went with Queen C2
uh which is yeah well sound positionally
but didn't prove white to have any
advantage
so I do really not know if we have to go
through the the entire game yeah perhaps
let's let's stop by somewhere over here
and move 16 yeah so a couple of moves
earlier so they traded a couple of
pieces and usually White's idea in the
English opening in this formations
respond on c4h against bonus C5 is of
course the goal for B4 but now you kind
of don't have the tools right unless
you're planning for Knight E1 Knight C2
which is a little bit awkward so white
instead goes for Knight G5 and F4 so it
tries to open files over there
H6 Knight to E4 then captured on e4 it
goes E5 Bishop takes Pawn takes and
apparently this one
is roughly equal I don't know white
tries to win oh okay I mean he does win
the pawn he captures yeah
Equity six back to D2 B3 but thanks to
this Rook on B3 I Believe In Black being
able to double on the beach that
probably gets enough compensation anyway
the game finished
relatively soon so we're here Queen E5
and now perhaps you can't really protect
this Pawn so D4 was played Rook G3 okay
so that's the point yeah you found it I
think with the queen big wizard the
queen is just a draw I believe
uh black can trade black can also
consider taking only two right and if
you take with the Rook yeah you
similarly keep all all your stuff
protected but the reason of G3 and then
just the Perpetual check
and I can see from the chat that people
are also kind of interested in seeing
what's going on in Christian karilla's
game if we could take a look at that he
is in the B section absolutely what's
interesting the B section I don't know
if there is any oh well there is one
draw for Christopher you but that's
about it that's about it in a way the
guys are like much eager to to fight
that's very good
um okay and also they play much slower
interest at least for Christian it's
only middle 25 he has the black pieces
here
and once again it was it was a peculiar
opening like basically why just yeah why
just play Z3 and says yeah okay not
interested in opening discussions I play
my thing you play your thing let's see
who does it better
and in a few yeah okay there have been
some transpositions but anyway the
current position on the board or maybe
we'll just click through it looks like a
hedgehog setup once again with colors
reverse with white pretending that he
plays the Black pieces
and black also having kind of a funny
setup with the queen on B7 rather than
Bishop on B7
okay Rook a to d8 Queen A2 Queen A1 yeah
so well black setup or rather white
setup now yeah looks pretty standard
and moves the queen moves the bishop
over here which is once again to some
who are not familiar with this line
might seem to be like a huge surprise
but in fact that's um once again I have
to repeat with colors reversed right
this battery is known and then whenever
you play D4 H7 will be targeted so that
actually makes a lot of sense
uh black girls G6 over here
well sometimes D4 is still a thing
because you can sacrifice on G6 but not
apparently not he has a queen to A1
Bishop to F7 Knight to E4 yeah but now
you're making a point that yeah G6
player to F6 now is not as protected as
used to be so your entire structure is
somewhat loose and then that especially
especially seeing if if like all of a
sudden gets aggressive laser 5 that he
might as well regret it because Knight
G5 E5 is hard to guard than White's
gonna capture the bishop and it seems
that the bishop on C2 is kind of a
passive piece but never mind even like
say if black doesn't have the bishop on
F7 even Bishop B1 Bishop A2 and then
opening for B4 so that that's some fine
positional chess we are witnessing okay
so it's kind of interesting because I'm
thinking you know I as I'm not a huge
fan of suffering on the more passive
side of a maroxy bind but it really
looks like in this one white is actually
kind of showing an excellent
illustration of just how powerful yeah
but that's you know it's not exactly
Marxism well that's more of a hydrogen
hedgework perhaps he is a unique animal
on a chessboard that well usually with
the lack of space you're happy to trade
the pieces because you don't have the
room to accommodate all the guys but
Hedgehog if you think of it like white
is perfectly fine so it's some sort of a
loaded spring and whenever you allow
it's D4 or B4 and then all of a sudden
all the pieces come to life okay so
Knight G3 for now why Knight G3 because
white of course seeking to play d3d4 at
some point and when you have a piece on
e4 then D4 is met with F5 and then Black
Blocks so ideally you want to control
the E4 square but not have the piece on
e4 Square I say to illustrate it I say
black girls A5 for whatever reason and
D4 there is no E4 right why it's going
to capture simply
okay so that's what we have for now uh
that's for Christian we do have first
result in the big group as well I mean
for first decider uh Dennis cartridge
opens the score against chadra akshat
yeah if we could just take a very quick
run through of this because I think we
also will be blessed with another
interview
for this one so uh for Daddy's coverage
yes well maybe maybe let's listen to
interview and then if he mentions the
moves like wonderful let's hear it now
okay and little magic company now okay
all right
all right I have some quick questions
for you just to get you going off your
Victory and uh can you just take us
through some uh interesting moments in
your game and just uh talk to the people
and tell them what you thought yeah sure
um I play the Italian I mean I've always
played Italian but I played some
um let's say weird move order with like
that was considered to be in the past I
would say just not so good for white at
all where I play Bishop G5 immediately
on move uh four uh it wasn't considered
to be that good because uh when black
didn't because black didn't Castle he
has ideas like H6 G5 and I cannot
sacrifice on G5 so the bishop on G3
looks very weird but of course engines
engines showed some ideas there that the
bishop on G3 is not that bad actually so
he played like their Bishop G5 H6 Bishop
H4 and now he played the most solid line
it was Bishop E7 back he was Bishop E7
back and now he wants to just uh
consolidate play normal position telling
me that my Bishop on on the king side
will be not very well placed I would say
so there okay I mean the guy who plays
this all the time is white is uh them
Shane Quantum is I would say the
the biggest expert in these in these
lines so I was really looking very often
at his games regarding this so after
Bishop B7 you play Bishop G3 immediately
forcing some D6 and now black threatens
to get my Bishop with Knight A5 so uh
there you push A4 and now okay so now
this this position is
I mean of course engines gives just
zeros all the time but I think it's very
interesting like there are a lot of
plans there uh so after A4 he played
Castle C3 and now let's see and now here
uh he played in my opinion one of the
best plans there black has he played
this like g69 H5 I did to get my Bishop
so G6 H3 uh he played now King G7 first
I played Knight D2 he goes uh night and
now yeah and now he didn't go Knight to
H5 he which is the best I'm pretty sure
it's the best according to engine but he
has to like he has to find an idea which
I I found
to be honest very hard to see like in a
real game if you're not prepared with
the engine is to go Knight H5 and then
after Bishop H2 you go Bishop G5 with
the idea to go Bishop F4 and the whole
idea with with Bishop G5 I mean you
always have to calculate can I go G4 can
I go H4 stuff like that uh so
like I didn't really expect it because I
saw that he doesn't like that he's not
like really well prepared in that line
so I didn't expect that he's gonna play
there so he plays now Knight to H7 there
okay so now we are both basically out of
like there's no more like
uh so I don't really like uh after
Knight at seven so now we are both out
of book and okay but his idea is to
attack me very fast with F5 F4 just to
get my Bishop closed so I opened up the
scent that's a very interesting idea and
that line where I just pushed D4 trying
to sacrifice the pawn actually but if he
takes it I get a lot of compensation so
yeah now after D4 he didn't he didn't
take the pawn but now I think he's just
worse Knight G5 Knight G5 uh he took ag5
and now I played the move uh Knight to
B3 I think I actually I actually missed
weight today when did I Castle I forgot
to say castle so when did they Castle
this the whole thing uh
D4 Knight G5 no wait somehow I missed I
think after you play King G7 I probably
no wait yeah it's almost somehow I have
a castle there and so now in this
position after Knight B3 his spawn
structure is I mean he has some ideas in
a Blitz game I think it could look very
dangerous for black to attack me in the
king side but here I played Knight B3
keeping the center just like trying to
keep it open and to be honest here I I
loved my position uh because it's very
hard for him to uh go anywhere nice with
with his knight from C6 he tried to go
like later on Queen E7 98 but after D5
the Knight again cannot really move
anywhere so I really got like I would
say one of like let's say a king's
Indian structure where I'm I'm super
fast on the queen side and then I don't
know to be honest like I felt like I'm
completely winning and then at the
moment I was like okay it's not so clear
he has some ideas so
it's on it like I just moved my Bishop
back Queen C2 C4 C5 and I think that
there it's just I think it's over like
maybe maybe the engine could find some
some tactics there but uh positionally
talking he is completely done I also
liked at the end when he pushed G4 how I
played the A6 move that's I think a very
very nice move where I just like kill
his counter play completely probably
even just taking the pawn should be
winning but this seemed like the the
safer option all right well thank you so
much for coming on uh and I wish you
great luck in your uh next rounds and I
hope to see you back thank you very much
wonderful that again was Dennis
kandridge on his big win over akshat
Chandra an excellent way to start the
tournaments and once again thank you
very much to Jacob Sanders for providing
us that interview with the players uh
now Miro is there any games that I guess
we haven't taken a look at yet maybe
there's still a few more interesting
points to look at yeah right well we
don't have that much time so just like
let's quickly jump from one actual
position to the other with without
rewinding to yeah what what has happened
in the in the opening it's like Cheryl's
game we've already seen right so it's
h4h5 white went for uh while trying to
loosen the king side even further right
yeah
uh that actually I can predict what's
going to happen in this game nothing
comes not in terms of result but I mean
usually you spend enormous amount of
time with both colors like white I mean
okay let's talk it without without
keeping my colors reversed because that
confuses me so you always look to make
like D4 or B for work and then with the
opponent always have to watch out for
you so pretty much any move like I
played H4 and they think okay next move
he's gonna go D4 B4 or next move or next
move so that makes it that by move 25
okay they've actually passed it 29 but
she really is on seconds
and white still has 20 minutes but this
20 minutes are easily spent in such a
complex position so mind you only one
pair of Pawns exchange so everybody
everything's on the board and then
usually by move 40 it's absolutely
clarified because someone loses his
nerve usually the white like pushing D4
but it's not necessarily bad it's just
like I mean it creates the open fight
and then yeah you don't have any time so
you do it absolutely okay so here is
that then we have a round knock and
mikhailan and here is our gioko piano
with some very yeah yeah nice
maneuvering and potential attacks for
white so white is trying to get there so
well why they actually played D4 which
is quite interesting because this
potentially allows this queen to kind of
join right
yeah well Rook D7 that's what he did so
he guards B4 he goes uh sorry B7 he
guards F7 potentially who knows I mean
after some sacrifices yeah it might come
in handy right
so this D4 is quite a bold move and I
suspect since he went for it he has in
mind something along the lines of C5
just breaking it open everything so if
black captures then of course are taken
E5 and second of the trying to make
things happen on the king side while
these days the bishop on A7 the queen on
A6 are still stuck I don't know if it
works but that would be that would be a
very logical continuation for white
let's see let's see how this one to keep
our eye on this is a really nice one
yeah and then we have landiban against
Gunther where it is actually an end game
uh lend them on being a pawn up right if
I can count still
um well well maybe not for long because
King D6 happens and then after King E4
there is a check on F6
and the good question would be who is
better and why
because yeah that's a very confusing
position that one
yeah if it wasn't for all that analysis
I mean just would be so easy yeah except
for that who's better and why part
all right but but yeah I mean what I see
I see the bishop which usually is
stronger than Knight if we are talking
about play on both Wings right and
somehow black spawns on G7 and H6
supposed to be vulnerable but they're
not
and then King G4 he also has a check on
F6 like not letting not letting this
King to go to Jesus right so yeah
perhaps black has control over the game
and it's move what it's moved 36 once
again black is down to one minute
Lenderman is well on half an hour or
something yeah we'll see and how about
the a group a group already had three
results right so right we've missed
supper maybe we've gotten Moon oh well
there is one more so you young ye oh
yeah a draw against one of our top seeds
well one Yen right okay I don't know
whatever happened in this game but that
they've reached well The Rook End Game 3
pawns age and that usually is considered
to be a draw
so that's the only one which is going
Ganguly against vidit or rather 2700
competitors yeah so let's let's try to
try to understand what's there I was
actually a very funny opening line where
at some point it would seem that white
was getting somewhere and he has won a
pawn but since then he's still he's
still kind of up a pawn but who cares
right in a little bit of trouble this
one this one is as well it's a huge Pawn
right so D3 if black to move I think we
are safe to say he wins this bishop
before it looks like the Knight will
come under attack the Knight had to move
obviously the pawn would be able to
promote all right so that's Bishop E4
and okay is Reddit winning or not that
that's a good question because
um so now that the good thing the pawn
is pained and attacked at the same time
so now Bishop before Knight F I'm not
even sure if one or F3 I'd say F1 for
now
um I guess Bishop B1 is what you do you
can't really go D2 because The Bishop's
taken and the pawn stopped right
and if you go Bishop B1 white might as
well might as well just play a four it
turns out because D2 once again I mean
it threatens The Bishop's hanging but
you can take you can take and then and
the knife protects the bishop Knight
protects the bishop and it actually has
a chance to win in this opposite colors
because he's up two points I mean it
won't be surprised if black still holds
a draw but obviously that that will be
going for it yeah that there will be a
huge mistake to do so
uh however if we think of yeah like
probably Bishop B4 is not a bad move or
an alternative could be Bishop C1 so if
white goes to F1 E3 is also controlled
and then you want to make use of your
king so try to get well ideally
somewhere around D4 and then if it
happens
so yeah there is still
the heat is still on there
the heat is still on so far a bus off is
the only who won the game and it well
quite conveniently with the black pieces
I mean that's that's the best part of
the tool it's actually quite frequent I
mean you're gonna get that there's gonna
be a lot of rounds where there's four or
five draws all together so it's very
nice whenever you get any decisive
action at all yeah I want to say I've
almost been in his shoes while playing
full Classics in 2018 so yeah I made it
to a tournament and I got black pieces
in the first round but this is where the
similarities stop
because I lost yeah I'm not sure if you
want how much you want to go into detail
of what happened yeah well if if you are
interested in in my description of that
my participation in full classic I tend
to say that uh on a distance of eight
rounds I made
one more Point than Alexander motilev
who is known as well European Champion
was 2700 at some occasions and the truth
is kind of silly truth is that I've lost
against him in round one and we shed the
last place so I was playing terribly but
he he even worse yeah yeah
but starting starting from round one I
was doing better than motor live at
least I mean so that's kind of
complicated
uh anyway so that's the only game which
is in progress uh there is uh something
in the B tournament streak so there's
still three games
yeah well perhaps Cheryl's game is the
most entertaining anyway
so they are pushing pawns left and right
after Queen B1 A5 kind of controlling B4
just in case white girls Bishop E2 yeah
this bishop in fact I mean it had some
no no he never he'd never been to B1 it
was it was my my ideas to put it on B1
yeah so anyway the bishop is now back to
E2
and black eventually goes G5 so now
since black weakened the F5 Square let's
move the bishop back to C2 honestly yeah
who knows who knows yeah so it really is
under pressure I have to say
uh and overall I must say that that's a
tough tournament nine nine rounds well
with this uh with this oppositions
especially like like the a no probably
each group but the a group nowadays it
grows year by year oh yeah because when
we were playing
2018 I think the the average was well
some around 2600 26 10 perhaps but not
higher than that and that was considered
to be like one of the strongest one of
the stronger ones right and now they
they've added like 50 points of an
average ELO so that means I mean it's
like everyone grew up with 50 points and
I know the goal is always this is kind
of a tournament that's meant for players
that are you know not going to get
invites to the sinkfield cup or
something but they've kind of got Beyond
these like imgm Norm tournaments it's
kind of this weird section that you find
yourself in and we generally try to
balance it out and have a b section
that's around about 25.50 rated uh in a
in an a section that's about 26.50 rated
but as you've kind of mentioned yourself
it is something where you know in the
past maybe sometimes it's skewed a
little bit lower and definitely over the
last several years this is a tournament
that has only grown in strength and it
keeps getting harder and harder to win
one of these classes class oh yeah well
that's uh precisely what you've pointed
out uh uh you have a lot of Swiss events
around the world but not that many round
Robins right it kind of turns to be sort
of a saying on the past and then it's
very nice it's include just love has it
and then at least for some people can
they they can play round robin with a
stronger position very good conditions
though I have to admit it despite my
like terrible play a few years ago but
yeah that's a that's a very good
tournament friendly atmosphere and
everything yeah
or writer when we see like literally one
decisive game image section not really
no well there are still three going on
here so hopefully someone's gonna
someone's gonna win
uh
so once again we'll quickly click
through okay Lenderman he's got his
Bishop on a f8 all right all right so we
are getting inside we win the d-pawn
black did win the Deep on oh okay so if
it's white to move white actually has
quite an annoying move F6 right
and it can be well the spawn can be
taken
in two different ways but then taking
with the Knight is probably just bad
okay Bishop Bishop G7 and not to lose
the H Pawn you have to have to go back
and that's that doesn't look good I want
to say that even like F3 and the
possibility will be so I know wait the
Pawn's gonna Pawn's gonna run away so
maybe you have to be a little bit more
aggressive maybe F4 and the material is
very limited but the king is active
right the Knight is this is really silly
on G8
very nice how the black king can't just
enter so easily in this position either
yeah yeah well we could run over and try
to take that Apon yeah but we kind of
have everything under control right and
it's rather white king which is like
seeking the way to perhaps even trap the
Knight rather than take the pawn uh okay
so F6 but the real debate is of course
that black captures here Bishop H6 and
white does get the ball kind of uh
dangerous age Pawn but black also might
have some resources a knight F5 and
nasty foreign
you're probably getting F3 and then a
lot of jumping here and then at some
point as you've mentioned to Anton yeah
the Knight sorry the king runs to well
the queen side pawns and maybe you trade
the Knight for the passport so it's
quite sharp yeah in this line it's much
easier for the black king to kind of get
into the positions yeah so being being
on lindenmann's place in this position I
think I might try to delay if say oh
wait a sec but if you delay of six his
next move is H5 and F6 is no longer a
thing at all right because if six it's
always going to be captured with the
pawn so it's now or never then yeah it's
no one ever
alrighty but it's move 30 years 40 for
white to make and then from 40 is
notorious but like people making
mistakes on move 40. yeah and you can
see the clock times there these are
usually off by just a little bit so it
might not be exactly 43 seconds but you
can see uh that Gregory is actually
under quite a lot more time pressure
than his opponent but with only three
moves to make uh maybe we'll be able to
get out of this one uh yeah and then
what else ah and was it was it yeah
sometimes you know I'll just predict
something leave this variation on the
board and it stays there but this one is
updated this one I'm actually very
curious actually it's getting better
actually look I mean yeah yeah I kind of
called it up to all everything all the
way yeah all the way to Bishop F4 and
then Rook e to D1 okay and that's yeah
that's sacrificed upon black has a
couple pieces really offside here on the
queen side so this is a really cool
concept yeah and it might even work yeah
it does seem to work I mean especially
like if he trades it's it's you know
that's bone sacrifice for for initiative
in 3D scope with Dolby Surround right I
mean white kind of literally has all the
forces attacking the the king and then I
wouldn't be surprised like next move
Knight G7 just works I don't want to
calculate too much but I believe it just
works because you have like all the
pieces literally
okay hold this for just one pun uh yeah
so then that seems to be that seems to
be very promising for white and then
once again shirella all the all the
pieces on the board and uh yeah yeah
yeah so they do make more moves uh
Bishop to G5 yes Bishop D1 was played I
mean it's amazing that it's sort of a
pendulum this bishop yeah this d1c2 and
then back to D1 E2 and so on this is why
you've played in these before you're
able to see it all coming H6 uh Knight
to H2 so that he intends Bishop G4 now
very nice and yeah 97 I suspect so
trying to control I suspect we have F5
E4 is what bothered him and then yeah
like if you take white takes and still
gets control over those lights quests
yeah why the last Knight D4 but he will
trade the dark Square bishop and that's
sort of a cheating you know Jonathan
like when you fight for light squares
where's the dark Square Bishop but
trading yeah yeah and then the black
dark Square Bishop is really silly so
that's why he apparently didn't play a
five he went Knight to E7 then white
gives E4 anyway restricting the Knight
intending to play Bishop G4 uh Rook C2
d8 rookie 3 so once again guarding the
pawn and he is planning Bishop G4 and
Knight F5 or Knight G4 yeah so that's
that's a very very tricky position
because I don't think black is like in
real trouble black also has kind of has
moves Bishop E6 yeah exactly what's
played so he controls the line squares
but it's very intense and also she real
is down to his last minute remind me
what move they're actually on here
34. let's move forward six more moves
from here yeah and Christian is on last
minute and already for quite a while
because when we are checking I think
somewhere around here when he played A5
he already wasn't like 37 seconds yeah
G5 was a big decision yep
we'll see what happens with this one
also we are always taking a learning
draw they say and the chat yeah oh well
someone actually figured out my emote in
the chat well I do have any milk yeah
cool so if you are here joining us if
you're on Twitch if you're on YouTube we
are hanging out with you feel free at
any point to send some questions you
might be able to influence a little bit
of the show and I'm hearing from pumpkin
the cat huge shout out to Pumpkin the
cat that vidit is potentially in time
trouble too so it might be worth taking
a look at that one once again it will be
in the a section oh yeah it's a section
the only game going is vid oh yeah we
were trying to figure out what was
happening with this what it's like yeah
very strong I have to yeah I have to
update this one yeah well he's down to
his last minute so what happened after
Bishop B4 was in fact A5 also makes
sense yeah well we'll get it closer
maybe you're gonna win the 18th one at
some point uh right King F1 Bishop
before
okay Knight F3
and I'm just wondering if you know with
this king of one was a terrible blunder
because there is Bishop D1 which wasn't
available previously and now you kind of
cannot really take the pawn and white is
threatened by Bishop E2 push the king
away then go D2 and win win the piece
finally so I wonder if there is a move
for white unless it's Knight D4
because yeah allow Bishop B2 and you're
just toast
or King G2
then D2 happens yeah and then he's just
ready to go anywhere right so he doesn't
even need the chair very good for black
yeah he doesn't even need the check said
well perhaps he's just waiting yeah I
don't see I don't see oh well
is this and I know but this once again
allows allows D2 and
if all all sorts of threads up to like
Bishop takes G4 I mean it's yeah
something to think about I guess he just
just blunder Bishop D1 Ganguly huh also
having like 12 minutes on the clock so
it was yeah that is weird
this is obviously it's I mean Vivid is
obviously one of the stronger players in
the tournament but uh yeah yeah just
gonna come down to what is going to
happen with this d-pawn and Ken white
find some sort of solution here
um
and uh just to answer some of the
questions a lot of people I think are
wondering do we have cameras for this
event and unfortunately we actually
won't uh kind of the issue with having a
live show is either we can have the live
chat and be able to talk to all of you
wonderful people who I must thank for it
being such a wholesome chat today it's
really been fun talking with you guys
but uh we will not actually have any
cameras we will be having some
interviews and we've seen that already
with some of the games that have had
decisive results so we've been able to
speak with a few of the winners
um oh yeah
um shall we say where where they're
playing they're playing at the beautiful
Chase hotel right all right well I'm
hearing from the producer that we can
actually leak where they're playing I
always I feel a little bit weird you
know saying we're like players are
playing I don't know yeah I don't know
you know you guys have been good I mean
I'll give you that but you know there's
some weirdos out there but they are
playing at the Chase Park Plaza which is
uh one of the nicest hotels here in the
St Louis area it's a it's a fantastic
place to play uh play any tournament and
it's just really a historical building
very tall building easy to see from
anywhere in the city
[Music]
okay so the chat has to has the the
question how so perhaps Ganguly was lost
before that I wasn't so sure because I
was thinking of Knight
f193. this is the way to at least kind
of have control over D1 but you might be
right chat maybe maybe Black's still
winning and maybe the pawn that will
actually promote is not the Deep one but
the a pawn I mean since he went A45
maybe he goes A4 up 93 he goes Bishop B1
moves this guy away then then in the
right moment takes gives the three but
promotes a a pawn yes I won't be
surprised yeah I won't be surprised
there was already problematic for
Ganguly so we will have if this ends up
as it looks for now we will have a very
very strange situation where like both
games that are wall in first round are
one with the black pieces yeah then they
keep telling us the why it's supposed to
have an advantage in the opening which
is well perhaps not the case
it's also nice to have a rating
advantage over your opponents that also
seems to go quite a far away oh yeah I'm
winning games even with the black pieces
yeah that that's how it works
uh alrighty and then for Christians game
and yeah and then in the B group no one
seems to be finishing the game anytime
soon I have to say
the B group so Christian will Christian
make it out of time trouble that that's
the big question right so move 37 is
what we have
move 37 still well not so much time for
for Christian but with streamers to go
and he actually he actually is quite
solid right yeah right so so the point
is at some uh yeah white perhaps kind of
slowed down a little bit with Bishop C3
not saying that he had anything better
than that and black went for a five
which trades a few pieces and and black
all of a sudden it's full control he
attacks the D3 he's ready to jump to D4
and might as well look for the way to
play e 5 E4 there which by the way black
just thought white just stopped with
Bishop F3 yeah this looks like white had
that on the radar but this does look
like a huge kind of turnaround I mean we
were kind of looking at that F5 square
like maybe White's gonna get some sort
of huge Advantage here but obviously no
F5 Square for you now uh well the kind
of the last name is clever because now
if you capture on B3 white can take
right and then eventually take on CC I
don't know trading queens or just
letting black trade but eventually the
knights taken on C6 and uh yeah but
other than that other than that you're
gonna play Knight D4 for instance or or
just just some move and I don't think
black is in that much trouble
and here's just a little bit of a fun
fact about uh Christian carilla he's
actually the only competitor in this
tournament that actually is uh official
fee day rating is actually inactive he's
won yeah that has not been playing in a
lot of tournaments he's been doing a lot
of commentary not a lot right yeah but
because the feeling he's like he's
always around yeah
this Christian route but but it turns
out yeah turns out he he went inactive
and what does it take nowadays to go
inactive the you don't play for a year
two years it's uh yeah it's an entire
year of not playing
um and then you end up going inactive so
it's actually I mean it's hard to get
back into something like this like I
imagine like you take a year off
um I know even if you're you know
playing at a low level like I've seen
people just like take a year off and
they're like oh I'll never get back into
it but uh it's good to see Christian
here and by the looks of it things are
going fine so far in round one
uh all right it's a knight to D4 push me
before yeah once again the game's going
White's fighting for the light squares
like baseball G7 is still passive but
yeah not as scary for black as it looked
a few years ago
uh so let me let me once again check oh
whoa whoa whoa whoa what's going on here
yes oh quite a like a black actually
does go for more stuff so Rook traded on
D1 Queen C4 yeah trying to bring the
queen in Knight to D6 now interestingly
the pawn is not taken instead he gets
Queen A4 targets The Rook so perhaps it
goes like this right so you can't really
in some distant remote variations you
probably cannot build the queen because
the rook's hanging
so perhaps that's why Queen A4 white
captures on F7 black captures on e4 Rook
to E1 Knight G2 F6 so it's now on never
I believe he has something yeah well
some sacrifice here or there uh well
does Bishop H6 just win would be one of
my questions because Queen F5 is such a
a wait a sec maybe we'll do it in a in a
clever way how about how about going
here I don't know if it's a good move
it's just a guess but yeah we attacked
the bishop on A7 and if Bishop captures
we have a check followed by uh Queen
takes rook and this has to be winning oh
there's a lot of cool stuff then he yes
there is that now let me see Knight G2
F6 what is this thing what's down to
seconds it's still oh whoa It's only
moves 33 so that's an exciting time
trouble so white is probably with it
winning
white is probably winning but
yeah I mean he's done on time and
well now we officially kind of getting
confirmed that the time this plane you
see on this board does not run out of
time completely yeah yeah uh so he did
take on H6 so my first guess was I don't
know if it was correct but that that's
something that happened in the game at
least
now lingering in the position Bishop
takes H6 wow yeah Queen check is a
threat
huh
and I think we actually have a little
bit of breaking news we were taking a
look at that Vivid game from earlier I
believe he is actually officially yeah
he has officially won yeah absolutely so
Bishop G2 D3 Bishop E4 A5 King F1 yeah
perhaps this bishop D1 was there and
that was actually the final move yeah
absolutely uh good news we actually have
an interview with vidit so he's going to
be able to give us a little bit more
insight into his game
all right all right thank you so much
for coming on the show uh if you could
just take me quickly through some of the
key moments the cool parts of your game
and uh tell me what's going on you know
um in the opening I was under some
pressure
um Surya played this line which I hadn't
checked in a long time
and I'm pretty sure I did not play
correctly in the opening phase and he
found this nice idea of Bishop takes on
S6 which gave him an extra pawn and my
only compensation there is that I have
two Bishops but
um it looked really very good for white
and I was in trouble
uh but at some point he also made an
inaccuracy which was very
um surprised with uh after that he could
have just put emergency brakes and made
a draw but um as he was better for most
of the game he wanted to play on which
turned out to be a mistake because
suddenly I had a past pawn and these two
Bishops and it became very unpleasant
for him so overall to sum it up I would
say that I was lucky to win this game
and
um
most likely it would have been a drawer
he would have won so I'm lucky today
we'd love to hear it uh it's good to
start off the tournament on this note
and we look forward to seeing you back
here and good luck in the rest of the
tournament man thank you an excellent
start there for vidit who mentions that
he did happen to get a little bit Lucky
in that you get one of those classic
situations where when your opponent is
better for so long that they actually
try pressing on in order to try to win
the game all right Jonathan so that
means the a group finished the round
officially with two wins for black and
three draws right so it's vidit and uh
the it's the Ninjago boss of who are the
leaders of the only one round yeah very
respectable results so I guess we'll
head back over then to the B section uh
yeah wow wow it is it is going on and on
oh
yeah well at some point it looks like
one of those chess studies when you look
at it and you think okay someone just
randomly throwing some pieces on the
board right it can't be the real chess
positions here Knight to E8 and Knight
to E8 Knight G5 could this be every move
could this be a blunt I mean oh wait a
second so Queen to D1 it's
ah so after the queen trade black might
have two yeah Queen trade Group trade
and then all right you can actually take
this guy wait a second isn't it black
like out of the woods and more than that
because Knight takes Knight takes but
it's actually perfectly fine the Knight
is not lost because King F7 right so
perhaps what you do I mean it can't be
that you have any other move after Queen
takes this D1 right so you have to take
and then black captures the bishop here
though you do have an alternative you
can play H4 the knights really can't
leave every single move a counter attack
yeah you never take stuff just attack
something different yeah that's an
impressive game by the way yeah but then
it's like oh well it's not the Android
key 7 I thought the control to to guard
B7 to roll the sevens right but then
once again it's not that far but it
keeps jumping around
that's crazy Rook H7 you know General I
don't know if it's good I don't I don't
care it's 1966 Pawn takes this is how it
has to be there it is you've called
everything so far basically uh well I
don't think this this one this will
happen but that's an exciting game I
have to say that's exciting game uh I'm
just wondering if white really well
feels like he missed something so this
felt like done can you tell me what
moves around here because we can see
that both players are under five minutes
yeah 21 is move 36 and so there is still
like four moves to four moves to reach
the position that's right this is why
you do tactics this isn't insanely
critical position a lot of wild stuff
could happen here and we'll see if they
can work it out in the next five minutes
yeah well by the way we are so much
carried away like trading the Queens
I'm just thinking can this be all of a
sudden that black can allow himself to
do this because he can't get in there is
no check there is no checkbook you can
play Queen E7 though right but then who
knows maybe black is in time to to
defend because there is Queen D1 and
queen is not that far away any longer
King yells I mean if you need even even
like Bishop can join some time it's just
that I have to make sure that I'm not
getting checkmated immediately which
there is no guarantee about
well so you can imagine you can imagine
how kind of how complex this is hard
enough with an hour on your clock
imagine five yeah yeah
I don't think we I mean it was a draw
but I mean maybe was there anything
interesting uh Christopher you Brandon
James yeah let me click through like
like starting from move 10. and I'll
call this one it was a joke of piano of
some sort and then on move 20 I mean
pardon me for doing this but that's uh
how I usually I have the opposite
approach I watched the first 10 minutes
and then just kind of like the first 10
moves and then I get home yoga piano I
give up
that's fair yeah but what I'm doing it's
like 10 10 moves or five moves into a
while and then to see okay so this is
still kind of okay for both and in five
moves well well it's probably slightly
more pleasant though with the bishop
with uh like A4 Knight C4 setup
so he can go C3 transfer the bishop and
then look for either A5 or B5 push
and yeah of course now that the game's
over we have well computer notes and
computer of course makes full of me by
saying black is slightly better no yeah
just to let you know right yeah and then
something like this has happened and
they've they've just repeated basically
this structure was never never changed
yeah so not much was going on there at
least
not much was going on there unlike in
this uh
sadhuani against mikhailan and the H4 is
on the board right yeah which Four's on
the board
whoa
what a crazy game that one is
so yeah probably you just go back and
then white eventually has the tank right
and probably has to take on B7 wait a
sec do you
I just thought by any chance maybe you
play C4 just didn't want to be yeah but
he he does have Bishop B8 so maybe
that's kind of way too optimistic
probably just take right and still a lot
of like night jumps
yeah the knights are going to add some
very sufficient complexity to this game
yeah yeah yeah and very easy you know
well it's it's easy to forget because
after all the mess that happened yeah
it's easy to forget to kind of um try to
count they try to do the head count yeah
and materials equal interestingly enough
right all that happened between us all
right
we just made a few trades yeah but
that's one crazy game honestly
and they do reach the time wait a sec I
think something has happened again uh
well he went rookie seven he possibly
blunted Knight E5 because this this
looks very this is your line this looks
very dangerous
uh well yeah and what do you do then
because he's also like he probably
played this rookie seven last last
seconds for lack of a better move in
about 20 seconds
yeah but maybe the idea is not Rook to
H7 yeah yeah you're welcome to show the
line again but there's going to be a pin
after white yeah so something active
perhaps like like you go to
E2 a check
takes no but that's what I'm afraid of
like like you go for something active
and then you are the one getting
checkmated because Knight D6 you can't
go to G6 The Rook is gone and then white
joins the action with the broken both
Knights and the g pawn and then that's a
nightmare
so he actually did play Knight H7 and
now this this showing of beautiful night
at night H6 I believe just wins on the
spot wow and this is what was actually
played we got Rook to H7 yeah Rook to H7
is the current position all right so we
were expecting Knight takes H6 yeah well
which isn't the bad at all I believe
right so he has to capture then the
Rooks attacks a rook G6 the only move uh
captures you can't really protect B7 if
you even if you'd like to because moving
the pawn means Knight C6 attacking the
bishop threatening to check so you limit
it to capturing F6 Knight B7 and yeah
well maybe C4 gives like a chance maybe
that oh wait a second but now all of a
sudden may I go back to my to my you
keep running to play poor idea because
yeah well B5 yeah and C6 is protected no
so it's not that not that easy
and if you want to exercise in tactics
we can continue because Knight C6 Rook
C6 there is checking by check yeah I
mean that that's crazy you might be able
to throw in the pawn takes P5 yeah no I
mean that that's a crazy position that's
so rich with tactics Knight takes H6
played that's move 40 for white so he
can exhale black I mean not not much to
you know not much to do he has to
absolutely has to take so that's already
played hg5 that's the current position
possible and this will give them a
little bit of time to try to figure out
what the heck is going on wow that that
was that was wild that was wild I have
to say uh all right sir to to Christian
the Christian uh they've also passed the
time control so that's move 42 for
Christian and tigran
um and what we've seen last time was
Bishop E4 but Christian simply traded
one to Queen F7 by the way hitting this
guy and this guy at the same time
B4 ab4 EB4 if black wants his absolutely
not yeah yeah I mean yeah it doesn't
kind of doesn't solve all of the issues
on white squares but at least you're
getting rid of this H5 Pawn which is
very important
so the only kind of alternative viable
alternatively he might be debating with
himself is to go C4 and keep the B file
closed and you know maybe maybe like a
Black's position is that good that you
don't really need to win the H5 phones
that's the only debate is there any real
way for white to defend it like I know
there's like G4 yeah G4 looks ugly right
it would actually do or maybe you can
get away with this and then like okay is
not possible Knight E2 is a check yeah
so maybe maybe C4 is you know overall
it's just just uh all a strong move
because yeah the H Pawn is not running
away
and with C4 and this pawns being still
not made to play like as of course if
you'd like much more comfortable yeah
like B5 is going to happen a little
while sometimes that might be three will
be will be huge yeah so Christian
actually comes very comfortable out of
this out of this stunt trouble and yeah
have you ever played chess after like a
long period of inactivity or anything
that's what Christian gorilla is doing
yes yes I mean I mean you know you might
be thinking I've bragged only about like
slight part of my trans activities
believe it or not fall Classics 2018 was
officially my last chess tournament
before this September oh so that was
really loud I haven't played yeah I
haven't played like almost the whole
pandemic
yeah yeah we had the pandemic and then
the pandemic and how was it like coming
back was it was it tough I mean it was
you know it was a remaining League I
have to say so greetings to Christian by
the way okay and while he was meeting
with with my friends so to speak because
I've played oh well that was funny there
is a player
well a lot of you guys perhaps heard of
very respectable and yeah so that that's
what that's uh 2022 the year we are
living in currently and first game we
played it was 1998 so that yeah and you
know I mean when you leave everyday life
you still think of yourself as being
young but then you say okay I've made
somebody 24 years ago yeah you always
get hit with all right uh yeah so
there's been quite a few games with like
old friends and most of them finishes
friendly draws you know did you play
well do you feel like it was like
significantly harder to play after all
it is hard because the game I lost I
lost one game and it was very painful
because I've lost a good position
understanding that position is better
yeah yeah uh impose more than it figure
we kind of figured out that I've seen
more than my opponent yeah I just kind
of I out calculated myself I mean that's
the worst game to lose yeah right
but yeah but that happens after a long
break you you feel Rusty and you feel
like it was like tactics or mostly the
rusty part or what what was the most
difficult positiveness I mean I mean you
see a lot in fact because
I haven't played but I've always done
something just relate right right so
you're not kind of not really that
really bad the Miss kind of misrepared
or something uh the point is like you
lose the Rhythm right and then also I
always been like a quick player so that
there wasn't like time trouble wasn't
the thing and then all of a sudden like
I'm thinking for half an hour and if
you'd ask me what you're thinking about
I don't know
b5a B5 a B5 and you repeat it for half
an hour yeah and staring yeah yeah
that's that's that's terrible by the way
C4 was played by all right Christians so
we we're calling some moves of this
place all right
me okay
hey I got a laugher let's play G4
protect our Pawn uh G4 yeah
wow it might be interestingly enough I
mean as bad as it looks white has to do
something like if you let Queen H5
you're I mean you're the same way lost
positionally
[Laughter]
or down the pawn so maybe let's let's
just go maybe let's just play G4 and and
see what happens
like won't cry about this but you know I
protected my pun
yeah but then once again if you look at
this position look kind of a bit
seriously it's all girls about like how
quickly Black's gonna win
because the bishop is still passive
right so black will will have to put
some effort in it but I'm guessing funny
enough I'm looking at this one which
almost almost makes black queen trapped
but you can never really trap it and
since you cannot trap it you're very
uncomfortable like F3 is no longer a
thing because I'll either take the Rook
or if you move the Rook the G3 is going
to be an issue right so since F3 cannot
be played then G4 is always hanging the
Knight is the Knight can be moved Rook
can be made because Knight E2 well well
actually it might be that it's almost at
soup you have to play moves like Queen
B2 and such yeah it could be very
cramping yeah so that's that's not an
easy task for Harvard Union Christian
does pretty well after such a break so
maybe back to active players you know
back to yeah it's good to see him and
he's actually uh he's a coach here he is
working with all of the students at
Mizzou University so he's somebody that
we see around quite frequently he's
constantly teaching people and I'm sure
he has a lot of students that are
watching to see how their coach is going
to be doing in this event so it's really
cool I know he has a lot of support a
lot of fans uh and also that all might
be helping him out he also has a podcast
he's got the c squared podcast that he's
been doing with uh Fabiano caruana
uh right yeah so the podcast which I'm
secretly hoping to uh yeah
you want to publicly uh we can try to
put in a good word for you yeah with
Christian uh right since you've
mentioned the students I believe in a
group we have Oparin who is like a
technically a student of Christian yeah
we have one of his students we can see
we haven't checked in on him in quite a
while did he is this game over yet yeah
yeah yeah a group is a group is done
yeah yeah a group is done and he was the
one too
to give Perpetual to Ilya niznik with
the sacrifice on G3 right Rook takes G3
and yeah
so yeah one more time for the guys who
might just join us a group has already
finished round one so two winners it's
videot Gujarati and we had an interview
just just 10 minutes ago
and it's a boss of who won same with
black pieces against Jacobian and that
was that was perhaps kind of an opening
catastrophe right yeah it's a white
confused something was lost by by move
15. uh right so the B group is still
going three games survived the time
control Mark all right uh yeah well I
want to take a quick run around the horn
here yeah so let's see well actually
Lenderman there's something that we've
I've forgotten to mention entirely so
Bishop of fate
98 and Alex while he's done a very
interesting thing
so he went B4 okay which kind of allows
the black king in but also that would
allow the white king in yeah
but usually your advice like you have
the bishop and you try to put the pawns
on the opposite code yeah opposite
colored squares so that they interacted
that like was the pawn on B3 let's say
uh Bishop takes care of the dark squares
and then pawns control July squares but
perhaps and it was more 40 so there
might have been like a panicky move I'm
not sure anyway E4 allows King F4 Knight
F6 black will be using all the dirty
tracks don't take it right don't take it
yeah Bishop G7 is of course a Jack it's
of course a track and right yeah so yeah
G7 is not possible yet and isn't quite
kind of getting stuck a little bit
because now if you move the king
if you move the cane that King E5 right
yeah and you lose the if you ever want
to go back here you don't even uh well
wait I'm confused
King G3 King if I is not possible
because I was waiting for white to
plunder this one
it's not really it doesn't let me play
it I wanted to say that you can go
Knight H5 but you're a bishop down in
the final that's kind of when the lines
end ends because Bishop takes E5 Knight
takes G3 we trade the Kings go from
there but yeah but Knight H5 regrettably
there are a lot of simple ways to miss
himself yeah so King j3 might be an idea
but where do I go on the other hand like
like 2h4 or something
that's quite silly
anyway so all three games are still
going
uh White is white is absolutely winning
in this one
so the one against mikhailan and
what is this so the time the time's not
not added to the clock uh right I mean
that that's the point so half an hour is
not added yet okay they've crossed
because they've crossed it's more 46 or
something okay so they did receive 30
minutes at move 40. yeah well it does
look weird because the Queens have now
come off the board yeah yeah so so that
that's the one we saw here yeah we've
seen this one
and he counted on B7 Cloud C4 went Rook
D2 which is absolutely fine yeah King F1
Knight D6 so he's going after this C4
Pawn all right and perhaps it's not it's
not a lot black can deal because Rook H4
there is G3 Rook to G4 I'm not kind of
taking it immediately but I go King G2 I
go F3 or even F4 yeah
yeah I think he's just just winning
he's just winning up okay it'll take
some time because black of course will
not resign immediately we'll try to set
up some sort of some sort of traps and
so on but yeah
no questions asked why you should be
able to convert this one
and then Christian Christian's position
is is amazing as well and we have London
months and he's still thinking here as
to what movie
happens it's not pleasant at all
it's not pleasant at all
it's really haunted yeah like
what move do you actually come up with I
mean white at least like you have a
feeling white should be able to put up
some resistance
but how do you do it like we're thinking
okay let's
okay this one's gone at least we'll
bring the Knight to G3 and to F5 but in
order to get it to F5 I actually have to
trade the D4 Knight and when you trade
the default Knight
you should not be expecting black to
take with the Rook you're gonna take
with the pawn and Heaven yeah I have
those two guys that's that's terrible
all right well I'm trying to keep
so it actually might be possible that uh
sadwani has actually won a game yeah
they've gotten the result right here
right now and yeah Knight D6 was the
last move in the game wait what 96 was
the last move in the game black just
resigned huh it feels a bit early yeah
but fair enough he he kind of trusts his
opponent that was one Wild game so well
maybe he can explain it because we
actually have an interview with sadhwani
and he's going to be be able to break
this down and tell us a little bit of
his thoughts during the game
all right so thanks for coming on the
show Mr ronic it's great to have you uh
and that's like obviously an amazing way
to start off the event you know you love
a good strong first win uh tell me how
it happened you know break it down uh
tell me everything you want to tell me
uh in the opening I played this B3 idea
which is relatively new very there are
very few games and he didn't play in the
best way and I think I played really
well until a point and later I think in
the time trouble I have messed up
somewhere very badly I forgot about this
Moon Knight G5 it was a great resource
by him
then I found Queen D1
and then it's probably around equal
again but only white can play on and
then he blend out this uh trick like he
went rookie seven Knight F5 and he
blundered Rook at seven I have Knight at
six
and this trick kind of sealed the game
so
okay it was the Topsy Turvy game but I
look forward to playing much better
chess in the next games and I love it
here well obviously that's a great way
to start it off and thank you so much
for coming on and we wish you lots of
luck in the next rounds coming up thank
you very much of course
Jacob Sanders for That interview and
congrats again to sadhwani on this very
important win and if we can actually
just stay and talk about this for just a
second here do you think this actually
was too early to resign or do you think
this was actually an appropriate moment
oh well now that I'm affected with uh
computer it actually says plus five
point three so almost like an extra room
sure but and but it really depends on
how you feel about the game and
sometimes uh like do you trust your
opponent to convert it sometimes you are
so mad at yourself that well actually
you're always mad at yourself I mean
when you're losing but it can lead to
either you resigning prematurely which
was the case with same with Vasily one
chick on many occasions right so he kind
of punishes himself and he can resign
where us they don't we don't even
understand what's the evaluation of the
position if the guy resigns all of a
sudden and you figure out apparently
he's lost right or sometimes people do
the opposite and then okay the game
didn't go well for me that's why I will
make you play another 20 he moves right
yeah so here
once again it was it was Michael Leon's
choice and I think he might have been
mad at himself or like as
his opponent mentioned in the interview
like blundering this Knight H6 thing and
yeah in the end and also like like you
look at it you lose the C4 Pawn white
has two connected passports and probably
you just call it today
uh yeah I don't know
um I would probably play like a couple
of moves more and like try to try to
defend it and see what's exactly the way
I'll be beaten but yeah without much of
a Hope anyway very fair enough and as we
are kind of approaching sort of the end
of our show for today let's go ahead and
take a look at these standings for the a
group uh we can see that we had two
winners today vidit and nijat were both
able to get on the board everybody else
was able to get a draw uh which
unfortunately means two people had to
lose in order to get here I am so we
look forward to seeing what will happen
in the future days but let's also take a
look at the B group and see the results
we still have a couple games going on in
the B group but uh we want to give
congratulations to ranak sadwani and
Dennis kadrick who are able to win their
games today and there's still a couple
other people playing uh that are maybe
hoping to also get on the leaderboard as
well oh yeah so if you want any
predictions I Believe Christian should
be winning and probably will in his game
but I have absolutely no idea what's
going to happen in lenderman's and we
are about to sign off here but if you do
want to continue following the action uh
you can watch the rest of Christians
games or any of the other game that is
going on right now on leeches if you go
to the broadcast tab you'll be able to
watch it I want to give a huge shout out
thank you to all of the chat thank you
to everybody behind the scenes that
helped to make this possible we will be
back tomorrow uh we're going to be
starting there's a little bit of a delay
we are starting at 4 P.M Central Time
each day and we're going to be here
every single day we got eight more very
interesting days so I hope you guys do
decide to come back and I want to give a
big thanks again to Miro for all of his
help yeah that was that was a lovely day
in the office and yeah looking for more
where is Hans Hans has made the draw to
a chat I mean you should have figured
out by now anyway and if you want more
Hans action come back tomorrow don't
miss it to make sure that you're
following us both on YouTube on Twitch
everywhere that you can follow us on
social media and we will see you guys
for another round tomorrow
that's it
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited